tens of thousands of lives lost millions
displaced over a trillion dollars spent
the costs of the longest u.s military
mission in history are staggering it all
began with the u.s bombing of al-qaeda
training camps in afghanistan launching
what became known as the war on terror
less than a month after al-qaeda had
attacked the world trade center and the
pentagon
now with the last american and allied
forces gone from afghanistan and the
taliban that sheltered al-qaeda back in
power many are asking if this and other
anti-terror missions such as the one in
war-torn mali are worth it 20 years
after 9 11 is the war on terror a lost
cause
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests kristen hilberg is
a freelance journalist who has reported
extensively from the middle east for
german and swiss media and she says with
the war on terror the west has created
more terror empowered corrupt autocrats
abandoned like-minded people and
retained its own principles
and it's a pleasure to welcome daniel
gerlach he's editor-in-chief with the
north africa and middle east magazine
zenith or seen it in german and his
opinion the war on terror has set a
precedent now many countries are using
it to pursue their own interests
and finally we're very glad to have
tyson barker back on the show he's an
american political scientist working
with the berlin think tank dgap and he
says with the end of afghanistan and the
war on terror the u.s is marking the end
of the american unipolar chapter the
question is what comes next
and let me start by picking up on that
point uh tyson you say the withdrawal
marks essentially the end of america's
role as the indispensable nation the
world's policeman
yet
hasn't interventionism as well as
isolationism been a recurring feature of
american policy essentially uh
since the inception of the u.s do you
really think interventionism is going to
go away i well i think it's we're
definitely seeing a major uh drawback i
mean the the theme of restraint has been
a constant one in u.s politics for the
past 10 years it was something that
obama ran on it was something that trump
ran on um but biden's decision to really
make a final withdrawal from afghanistan
and also his pushing congress to
withdraw the authorization of use of
military force is really something
that's going to constrain u.s action in
the world and i think that will be a
generational uh change
daniel the mission in afghanistan like
many anti-terror missions elsewhere
morphed into state building was it in
fact utterly for naught or would you say
it did so some seeds that could flower
in future
well i think there is a a generation of
young afghans
who
haven't lived taliban rule and who
looked for something better for
something different who share
values of europeans and of their you
know generational peers everywhere in
the world that are connected to the
world so uh i find
devastating to hear the narrative that
all of afghanistan was always with the
taliban it was just like a big illusion
to think that it could be any way
different and
the west failed because they didn't see
that i think that is part of the story
but the other part of the story that of
course there is a new generation of
people who think differently
if that was worth the investment or
worth the cost is another story
but i think we see that all over the
world you know the narrative that the
middle east or the the muslim world is
just different and it makes no sense to
engage with it because it's always going
to weigh the same it was
i don't think that is a true analysis
we're going to talk a little later about
what kind of engagement could be
productive but kristen you say the war
on terror created more terror but if we
look at the original aim of u.s and
allied operations in afghanistan don't
we have to acknowledge that there was
some success in crushing al-qaeda's
ability to export terror yes but this
was finished in 2002
so the fact that the us date on started
to weaken the taliban
rule rulers and started to rebuild a
country or to export their own model of
you know centralized presidential
democracy this did not work out and this
is i think the big problem why the war
on terror in my opinion failed because
it was led with the wrong means and with
the wrong purposes you know we had the
wrong allies on the ground corrupt
politicians warlords that were brought
into political positions and these
people didn't have the legitimacy within
the people and within the country that
we were giving us the illusion so it's
it's very much about illusions i think
in afghanistan i agree of course that
you have a young generation of people
who want to live in a different way but
the illusion was that we really thought
that we could export a democracy model
and then we could install it with people
that we consider our fellow fellow
allies but they were so corrupt and so
engaged in in personal enrichment and in
drug business that in the end the people
in afghanistan would opt for the taliban
some of them at least i want to dig
deeper on the mission but first i would
like for us to look back 20 two decades
to september 11th it is one of those
dates that's absolutely etched into the
minds of all those who's experienced it
unforgettable both the horror and the
expressions of solidarity and
determination
september 11 2001.
one of the few who were buried under the
rubble of the world trade center in new
york city and lived was police officer
will gimeno september 11th lives with me
every single day
it never goes away for those of us that
were there that day
miraculously wilhemena was pulled from
the wreckage alive though with severe
internal and external injuries that have
not fully healed
giving up was never an option for him
so i tell people 20 years later one of
the things that i learned at night is to
never give up you fight till the end
but u.s president joe biden decided
enough was enough
and completed the withdrawal of american
troops from afghanistan
this decision about afghanistan
is not just about
afghanistan
it's about ending an era
[Music]
of major military operations
to remake other countries
so is this the conclusion of america's
war on terror
tyson your own opening statement ended
with a very similar question to that one
so let me put that one to you as la as
well as the question that you posed what
comes next america first cold war with
china
where is the u.s heading now i think
all of the above i would say in some
ways and and to be quite honest we don't
know what's going to happen with
afghanistan as well i mean as was
mentioned there's a
generation bulk a youth boom that has is
our digital native that are globalized
there's urbanization that's going to
cause a lot of resistance to taliban
rule and a lot of frankly probably
instability in that country so we don't
know if that era is completely over we
do know that the u.s large footprint is
is coming to an end um but it's you know
we were very unclear watching this clip
i was just thinking about what was our
mission what were our aims
and the
political leaders of the united states
weren't clear about the aims they
weren't clear about the discrete aims
yes they said that we want to make sure
that it doesn't become afghanistan
doesn't become a haven for al qaeda but
then we had people like laura bush great
first lady very well respected saying we
want to give rights to women and girls
so we have these conflicting messages
and some of this has come out in the
afghan papers since i think in the
future
the u.s is going to be much more clear
about how it describes its objectives
when it engages with the rest of the
world that will be in great power
conflict and frankly it's going to be
more isolationism with the united states
let me start with uh or stay with that
first mission that tyson just mentioned
the mention the the attempt to prevent
afghanistan from remaining a base for
terrorist organizations like al qaeda we
saw u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken in germany at the ramstein air
force base this week and he called once
again on the new leadership of the
taliban to do exactly that to prevent
their country from becoming a launching
pad for terror operations what do you
think daniel
will it become one certainly uh in the
attack on august 26 on kabul airport we
saw that islamic state does have a
foothold in afghanistan right now yeah
and the taliban and talban are
recommending themselves as the preferred
ally of the international community to
fight the so-called islamic state of
khorasan in afghanistan
look i think the the the conditions of
the war of a war on terror are very
different from what they were 20 years
ago uh the the enemy that's been that
the western countries have been fighting
more or less successfully in the last 10
to 15 years were domestic
enemies these were not some remote
terror organizations bin laden sitting
in
a cave somewhere literally in a cave in
afghanistan these were homegrown
young people
who
were inspired by this by this ideology
and who committed uh horrible attacks in
france and spain in the uk also in
germany
and that is a very different enemy that
the the western countries are facing
than they were like 20 years ago and
here
military means are pretty difficult to
apply of course you can go and say like
i want to go to the source of
inspiration of this uh the source of
legitimacy uh as they went after the
so-called islamic state in syria and and
iraq which they also declared a war on
terror but the challenges are different
and i think if uh the u.s or the western
militaries had
today's military capabilities in 2000 of
2001 namely drone warfare probably they
would have conducted this war on terror
in a very different way i want to go to
that point in just a moment but i would
like to get kristen first to weigh in on
the same question of whether you would
expect afghanistan now to revert to
being a base for terrorists we see the
new makeup now of the taliban government
it includes a man like sirajudine
haqqani who is a wanted uh terror
operator so what's your take but this is
not new i mean you had warlords in the
government in the western uh applied
government before you know you had
people like
dustin you know who
committed crimes against humanity so
this is not new but definitely the new
government that the taliban just
presented is obviously a disappointment
from a western point of view uh isis is
the islamic state is already there isis
this is their local
network there and they are quite
mightful and i think the taliban are
caught in this
really in this fight to present
themselves as some kind of new taliban
renewed more moderate taliban to the
west to get to keep the money coming to
the country because the biggest problem
is the economy obviously in poverty and
on the other side to keep all these
young people that are frustrated and
that are
kind of idolated by this isis and they
want even more stricter rules islamic
rules and they themselves are maybe
applying and so they are caught in this
you know they have to present themselves
as radicals to keep their own afghan
youth with them to not let them join
isis the islamic state and on the other
hand to keep the west financing their
own governmental
tasks so this is really the problem that
they face right now i think
tyson
daniel just mentioned a drone warfare
and it seemed to me at least that it's
surely no coincidence that the u.s
navy's mideast-based fifth fleet
announced this week that they are
launching a new task force with airborne
sailing and underwater
drones would you expect the u.s you talk
about isolationism but isn't it like
that that we will see war on terror
continue but just in this remote fashion
i mean that has been a trend in u.s
military culture for the past 30 years
and the us has always relied heavily on
technological capabilities to be much
more advanced than any of its partic
possible opponents that is its
its advantage in asymmetric warfare but
there are certain things frankly that
you cannot do with military force and
that is where the problem lays i mean
the the fact that obama dramatically
escalated the use of of drones during
his presidency was critiqued heavily and
was seen perhaps as somewhat of a
political loser not only in the
countries that were targets pakistan
afghanistan etc but also in countries
like germany which were heavily critical
of the use of of drones and how it was
seen in context of international law so
i do think that this is the direction
the u.s is going to go but i don't know
if it's going to have the political
outcomes that the u.s is going to hope
for you say heavily critiqued yet the
u.s continues to use drones it just
attacked a car in
afghanistan
a number of civilians died
the circumstances are still somewhat
unclear but
for a u.s population that wanted the
boots on the ground
out of afghanistan will there be
somewhat more appetite
for remote warfare as long as they don't
have to see it too clearly that's the i
think that's the most important point is
that this the afghanistan policy the
united states the war on terror is
really a domestic policy it's a domestic
american policy and how it makes sense
within that calculus within that prism
is what's going to work to the extent
that it is remote to the extent that
it's clinical that it's sanitized
it will be much more acceptable to the
american public especially if they're
not confronted with it on a day-to-day
basis with the lives of their youth and
it's better than regime change i mean to
be honest i mean everybody will be more
happy that the americans do not repeat
iraq because they went to iraq without
any connection to terror in the first
place i mean we have to maybe uh clear
this up again that the war on terror
was really not led in iraq it was said
that it was about terrorism but in fact
there was no link whatsoever between
al-qaeda and saddam hussein so they went
there in the end the americans brought
al-qaeda to iraq by their occupation
because really iraq became the hot spot
of international jihadism so this was
and this is one of the reasons why it
created more terror which is one of the
reasons you also have written recently
that uh the war on terror destabilized
the entire region of the middle east
drone warfare
no destabilizing uh consequences there
civilians killed obviously obviously yes
i mean obviously it's uh and you just
mentioned it you know on the
international law level it's not even
really debated you know until now so
there is a big problem about this but we
are used to the americans going
somewhere you know changing regimes
staying there making a lot of mistakes
bringing more terrorists there so from a
european perspective uh warfare this
remote kind of warfare would be more
acceptable i think
i see a far a far bigger problem here
um
for a long time
western powers in particular the u.s
thought that they have an exclusive
somehow felt exclusive right on the use
of these extra judicial means because
they have the moral superiority and they
have the the procedure
that every strike though it's debatable
if it's legal but there is a certain
procedure there are certain checks and
balances many countries in the world are
emulating this this uh without having
the necessary procedures probably
armenian
they're emulating the exact same thing
drone strikes well the drone strike use
of drone warfare is one thing but but
using them to strike political opponents
across their their own borders interfere
in in in regional conflicts
extrajudicial judicial renditions which
basically means kidnappings of political
opponents people they consider
a threat to the national security and a
threat to the national security can mean
many things president erdogan has
recently uh called one of his political
opponents in parliament a representative
of the the most ancient party of the
turkish republic a terrorist
like the use of the word terrorism has
been so inflationary and the references
to the fight against terror have become
really inflationary in a way and that is
that is a problem uh for the western
world because
it has lost the illusion of this moral
superiority and maybe the countries that
we're dealing with never thought that
the west had an exclusive right on this
it was just like a question of when
would they acquire these means and
russia and china and many small
countries in the in in the middle east
uh are using the same iran
so escalation and uh essentially at the
creation of precedence for
the use of or the abuse of uh some in
the region would even say
democratization of these means because
why would they yeah like i'm saying this
without without being cynical why would
the u.s have an exclusive on this kind
of extrajudicial uh operations outside
their own territory but i mean yeah but
this is a result of our own foreign
policy and even internal policy that we
all put under this big headline of war
on terror you know by fighting war on
terror we um recalibrated our own
foreign relations you know with the
whole mediterranean area for example we
went to all these capitals and talked
about our common war on terror in riyadh
the capital of saudi arabia in turkey so
we talked to these people everybody
committed himself to the war on terror
and everybody was thinking about his own
personal terrorists so it's bloggers
it's opposition it's muslim brotherhood
it's pikachu they are all the terrorists
that these districts
i want to come to this
a little bit later but i would like to
pick up one one more uh point uh before
we take a look at uh some of the other
places where in fact we are waging the
so-called war on terror and tyson the
point is this you as an american in
europe you will undoubtedly remember on
september 11th uh 2001 the profound
professions of solidarity from many many
europeans
it looked at that time like
a truly collective uh
sense of outrage um
where did that go where are we now would
you say
that there is
essentially now a great sense of
disillusionment here in europe how would
you how do you perceive it i mean it was
an astounding moment it was a unique
moment in history where not only in the
united states did you have 70 plus
percent approval rating for the bush
government a rally around the flag but
you had a world community that came
together in unlimited solidarity as uh
the then chancellor said um but it was
about the means in which it was
perceived pursued because we had the
bond summit we had a a wide coalition of
people supporting the idea of war on
terror which was instrumentalized and
weaponized by authoritarian states like
russia and china but still you had this
commitment to the idea and what happened
afterwards of course is that it became
the
instrument of domestic politics in the
united states you had a scared
population that wanted to see action
wherever were possible and an
administration in in the us that muddled
afghanistan that talked didn't really
say what the they said the mission is to
uh make sure that al qaeda is destroyed
and doesn't have a safe haven done very
quickly um and then changed the
objectives in afghanistan and then moved
to to the middle east up to today
a little short on time how what's your
perception of how europeans see the us
today in the wake of this shambolic
withdrawal from afghanistan i think that
they will have a deep reticence to
follow the united states into similar
missions in the future but i'd also
think the us will have the same
reticence to engage in those kind of
missions i also think that the idea of
the war on terror in europe is is a
bankrupt concept it continues to be
instrumentalized in places like syria
and china but it's not being used in
europe certainly that sense of
disappointment is prompting a lot more
calls here in europe for a more forceful
and autonomous european security pillar
but the fact is the record is mixed when
it comes to the success of european
anti-terror missions to date at the
moment the german military is engaged in
no less than 10 operations on three
continents one of the most dangerous of
them in the west african sahel
a german military patrol in eastern mali
they talk to shepherds in the area and
try to gain their trust and obtain
specific intelligence on planned rebel
attacks
after a military coup in 2012 northern
mali temporarily fell under the control
of islamists and other rebel groups
the international community responded by
sending the menusma un forces
around 900 german troops are taking part
another 300 german soldiers are part of
an eu military training mission
to get mali's own troops in shape to go
up against terrorists and criminal gangs
but mali's armed forces have had to deal
with widespread corruption and two
pushes in the space of a single year
all the while the islamists have been
launching new attacks and gaining more
ground
even so the german bundestag has
extended the german armed forces
commitment in mali for a few more months
will mali turn into the next afghanistan
and kristen let me put that question
straight to you
as was the case in afghanistan germany
has been concentrating a great deal of
its effort on training forces in mali is
that any more likely to work there than
it did in afghanistan well it's there
are quite some astonishing perils first
of all i think as in afghanistan we
follow the americans there now we are
following the french because the french
are really the main driving force in the
sahel zone and especially in mali so we
are not in the position to criticize
this mission but we are not putting our
own strategic analysis into this so we
are just following we are paying we are
sending some troops to show that yes
germany is ready to take over some
foreign policy responsibility even with
troops which is from german perspective
very special because we always kind we
like to build schools and stuff like
that soft power more than hard power but
the problem is that the same mistakes
are being repeated because again we are
looking for a local government as an
ally that is very weak that is not
perceived as legitimate by a lot of the
population and for example the french
are cooperating with militias that in
the end create more terrorism because
local population feels attacked and
feels um
put into this war on terror framing that
is not really um
that's not the reality on the ground so
misunderstanding of the cultural and
local conditions again daniel by far the
largest player in the sahel in terms of
the military operation there is france
it is now reducing its operation but
says it does intend to stay the course a
lot like the rhetoric we used to hear
from the u.s
what would be your advice to president
macron or his successor
i strictly don't give any advice to any
political leader because i think mena
middle east experts anthropologists or
whatever might be good at analyzing the
situation but not necessarily at giving
the right policy advice at the right
moment because there is a political game
going on that is sometimes far beyond
the expert scope
i think the french are going to stay in
the sahel and they're going to stay
remain engaged in the science of because
this region pertains to some fundamental
french interest and the french have been
there for a long time and so they feel a
certain responsibility and also have
defined the interest
natural resources security migration
stabilizing the sile is of course uh
important for the french and they have
their own way of of looking at things i
don't think president is going to
withdraw from this my advice for
everyone who's dealing with with with
these issues is to try to look through
the other person's eyes
i'm not i'm not advocating for talking
and negotiating with terrorist
organizations all across the globe but i
think it is fundamentally important to
try to understand what is the motivation
and what is the reason why someone is
picking up arms because that helps you a
lot to deal with this enemy or probably
to turn this enemy into an ally if
necessary let me give the last word to
tyson tyson our title asks whether 20
years later where we whether we can now
say the war on terror was a lost cause
what's your answer to that
um i i think that it is
yes i think it's it's pretty i mean to
be quite honest this has been a huge
investment in treasure and time and
resources and i don't think that we have
the outcome that was anticipated in
those first years and daniel doesn't
want to advise president macron what
would you say to makra
i would say uh
from the u.s perspective look at things
through other people's eyes but you know
the u.s sees
europe as the underwriter of this region
and this is the the future that we have
which is much more uh great powers like
europe like russia like the united
states taking responsibility in their
own neighborhoods thank you thanks to
all of you for being with us and thanks
to all of you out there for tuning in
see you soon
you